i don't want to spend a ton of time on
this today but i got a bunch of emails
from people since joe biden was sworn in
about
what is likely to happen from the
standpoint of donald trump's second
impeachment trial which we still don't
know when it will actually
take place but i think it makes sense
just as a reminder that yes donald trump
was impeached a second time before
leaving office in the house of
representatives
yes it will be up to the senate to vote
uh to either convict or acquit in a
trial that is going to take place at
some point in time
and it bears mentioning that republican
support for convicting donald trump in
the senate trial
grew over the last few days of trump's
administration and during the first few
days of joe biden's there's a politico
mourning consult poll released earlier
this week
where about 20 percent of republicans
now say they either strongly or somewhat
approve
of conviction of donald trump that's
up from the previous poll where only 14
of republicans said the same thing so
support
for conviction among republican voters
is
up but most republicans are still
against conviction
and of course it remains to be seen to
what degree republicans continue to
stand behind
the now former president donald trump
it's very partisan still
86 percent of democrats approve of a
conviction
uh 50 of independents strongly or
somewhat approve
of a conviction and again 20 percent of
republicans but really what it's going
to come down to
uh are republican uh senators
and it is mere speculation at this point
would mitt romney vote to convict mitt
romney voted to convict on one of two
counts in donald trump's first
impeachment trial
mitch mcconnell reportedly was pleased
with the impeachment of trump meaning
what the house of representatives did
presumably believed to be because
it allowed the republican party to try
to create
distance between itself and the then
outgoing now former president but
just because mitch mcconnell is pleased
that trump was impeached in the house
doesn't mean mitch mcconnell
has any plan to vote to convict uh
during the
senate impeachment trial of donald trump
so it simply has to happen now
a few just very very uh basic
ideas about this some have floated the
idea that
we forget about the impeachment trial i
think this would be a disaster
um if you do a if you if the house
impeaches they did it because they felt
they had to that's the way
impeachment is supposed to work it's a
responsibility if a president does
something worthy of impeachment then you
impeach
it would send a very bad signal about
the merely political motivations which
the the motivations are trump did
something impeachable
it will not look good if you do the
impeachment
in the house and then never do the trial
i think that that would be an absolute
disaster and it opens up the door
um to impeachment becoming a much more
political thing you know when marjorie
taylor green that
cookie q a non-congresswoman said i'm
going to
write up articles of impeachment for joe
biden before biden was even sworn in
that's the type of stuff that will start
to seem more on the level
of what happened to donald trump in the
house a week and a half ago
if uh there is no trial there must be a
trial the full process must take place
in terms of when i actually think sooner
is better i think the longer you wait
the more the the lower the chance of a
conviction goes
so i would like to see it soon the
senate can walk and chew gum at the same
time
joe biden can get things done even while
an impeachment trial is going on that's
my view
i'd love to hear from you one of our
sponsors today
is lucy and they are giving my audience
20
off lucy is a company founded by cal
tech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier
you'll find a ton of excellent reviews
online
from countless people who have used lucy
to quit smoking and vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical